BUT I'LL ACKNOWLEDGE THE
POSSIBILITY THERE COULD BE VERY
WELL BE DRAMA BEFORE THE
DEADLINE.
>> Bret: MIKE EMANUEL LIVE ON
THE HILL.
THANK YOU.
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY AND ALL OF
YOUR FELLOW AMERICANS ARE NOW
MORE THAN $21 TRILLION IN DEBT.
THE U.S. PASSED THAT THRESHOLD
LAST WEEK AS WE REPORTED.
DEIRDRE BOLDEN OF THE
FOX BUSINESS NETWORK TELLS US
WHAT ALL THIS MEANS.
>> THE U.S. GOVERNMENT JUST HIT
A RECORD, BUT NOT ONE WITH
BRAGGING RIGHTS.
WE ARE IN DEBT, A LOT OF DEATH.
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT SPENDS A
MUCH MORE THAN IT TAKES IN.
DURING PRESIDENT OBAMA'S TENURE,
THE NATIONAL DEBT NEARLY
DOUBLED.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS AGREED
TO GOVERNMENT BAILOUTS OF
NUMEROUS INDUSTRIES AFTER THE
2008 FINANCIAL CRISIS.
THIS PAST YEAR, THERE WERE A
DOZEN LARGE-SCALE STORMS,
COMBINED, THE COST OF RESPONDING
AND REBUILDING WAS ABOUT
$200 BILLION.
WHILE FEW CITIZENS FIND FAULT
WITH THE REASONING, THE MONEY IS
STILL SPENT.
RECENTLY PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED
FOR MORE MONEY FOR DEFENSE,
SUPPORTING THE FIGHT AGAINST
ISIS AND FUNDING THE DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS AND OTHER
AGENCIES.
SOME POLITICIANS SAY THERE IS A
LIMIT TO WHAT THE COUNTRY CANNOT
AFFORD.
>> THE GREATEST THREAT TO OUR
NATION AS WE OURSELVES.
IT IS OUR INABILITY TO DEAL WITH
THE FISCAL ISSUES THAT WE HAVE A
THE NATION HAD.
>> THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE DAN COATS HAS SAID
THAT WASHINGTON'S LACK OF FISCAL
DISCIPLINE UNDERMINES NATIONAL
SECURITY.